[MUSIC PLAYING]
DALE MARKOWITZ: I think the
best types of relationships
between mentors and
mentees are ones
where there's a really
unique fit between the two.
What do I mean by that?
Well, I get a lot of requests,
people asking for mentorship,
where they want to know how
do I succeed in data science?
Or, how to learn
machine learning more?
Please mentor me, give me
product ideas, whatever.
Something really broad.
And I just think, there are
potentially many good mentors
for this person,
but I'm not sure
that I'm particularly
well-suited to help.
STEPHANIE WONG: When you're
looking for a mentor,
make sure you do
your due diligence
by coming to the
table with research,
either about that person
or about the technology
that you'd like some help on.
So check out the
person on LinkedIn,
find out what their
experience is.
Or maybe you want to first
look at a white paper
or do some research
in that area,
and come to the
conversation with points
that you'd like
their opinion on.
TULSEE DOSHI: So my
advice for finding
a mentor in the tech industry
is honestly just to ask.
I think there are so many
amazing smart people who
would be more than
happy to give advice
and to share their learnings
and their knowledge.
RACHEL BEEN: Find
the person who's
willing to bring you
into a really, really
tough conversation.
A really, really senior
person without any sort
of preparation, but they trust
you enough to handle your own,
I think that's
the type of person
that you might
want to learn from.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Be very respectful
of your mentor's time.
Once you have identified
the person who inspires you
the most, who you
would want to be,
then reach out over
email or social media
with specific guidance
on the exact thing
that you're looking
to accomplish.
I find the more
details you provide,
it makes it easier for
you to receive help.
ALEXANDRINA GARCIA-VERDIN:
Find people you admire.
People you're
really inspired by.
And do some research
on the things
they have written
on the internet
so that they don't have
to re-explain basics,
since they probably already
shared these things online.
And after understanding
what it is
that you want to learn from
these folks, reach out to them
for virtual coffee if they're in
your organization's directory.
If they are external,
reach out to them
via platforms like LinkedIn.
And once you build a rapport,
keep chatting with them
once a quarter.
SHILPA VIR: The way to find
good mentor in the tech industry
is to just be open.
And approaching people
that you admire,
even if it's just
one small thing,
and asking them if you
can spend some time
with them learning about it.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Rather than
having one mentor that I go to
for questions
across the board, I
tend to seek out those I
admire in specific areas.
So for example, when I was
looking at moving careers,
I talked to a co-worker
that had actually
made a really similar move,
and got advice from her
on how to get started.
And in another situation
when I was really
hesitating for this big,
risky, but good decision,
I talked to another co-worker
who I find absolutely fearless,
and she definitely
helped talk me into it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]